hello everybody the prime minister
taking a special downing street press
conference for children an unforgiving
crowd at the best of times particularly
on climate change so honesty the best
policy on the cop 26 u.n climate summit
being hosted in glasgow in a week's time
it could be very very tough
this summit
and i'm very worried because it might go
it might go wrong
and we might not get the agreements that
we need and it's it's touch and go
to help move things in the right
direction the government has made a
significant announcement rich countries
have reached the 100 billion dollar goal
of global climate funding for developing
nations
this money was supposed to have been
delivered by 2020 but high income
nations fell short that's the case for
2021 and 2022.
the next three years up to 2025 are more
positive but for those waiting for the
money being years late is a big deal as
cop 26 president do you accept personal
responsibility for that and any
potential negative consequences for
negotiations at the glasgow summit we
are seeing uh progress through this
delivery plan i think this is the the
most transparent uh set of forecasts uh
of this nature that we've ever had uh
but of course countries will need to
deliver on this uh and secondly there is
more to be done
for climate vulnerable countries money
for adapting to the changes that are
already here is the key issue a matter
for many of survival our lives are on
the line we are on the front lines 80 of
our population across the region
are in low-lying coastal areas and if we
don't have the money to to
adapt to the changes that are already
taking place this isn't a an academic
issue for us whatever the concerns this
new funding is being pushed as a welcome
positive achievement with cop 26 now so
close and the uk's reputation as a
climate leader on the line the prime
minister is in real need of momentum now
the climate finance announcement will
help with that but there are still some
big problems that need sorting out like
agreement on phasing out coal agreement
on global carbon markets and getting big
polluters to be more ambitious in
tackling global warming
in just a week world leaders will
descend on glasgow and time is ticking
away as the summit by the prime
minister's own admission hangs in the
balance
hannah thomas peter sky news in
westminster